what isn't there's an awful people in
the audience who love you and so I will
write in calm down so I'm just gonna
give an opportunity for some of them to
say I love you
so we're that oh look at her blue hand
right up there yeah you already did it
can you okay what what's your name
Anna Anna and send-up were you from Anna
uh sorry sorry love Harrison if that's
the point
wait a minute get into that okay so
there he is he's not gonna you nearer
but okay you'll come in your eyes and
tell him oh wait wait for the music
what's with me
I love you
I know
consumer else have a go do you mind yeah
sure what you said about your name yoga
what yoga from Bantam Yoko Yoko Yoko
Yoko and you live here now
no I don't so you're just here from
Belgium on holiday I came for this yes
to see mr. Ford
yes meet-cute music there he is there he
is there yes there is it was music I
love you thank
took his name through the backdoor
wouldn't story of her life
Zachary here is Lady gaga